[Music]
i don't know how you got back but you
made a big mistake coming here oh
contrermo frere
the mistake was thinking you'd won i get
it don't think you do
but you're about to
and so will that idiot sheriff in his
wife
and your little dog too
[Music]
beautiful
who are you
where
are my manners
sonic
meet knuckles
my new bffae
bestest friend forever and
ever yeah
i make this look good
oh great the winter soldier
for a guy named knuckles you are really
bad at punching you're no match for me
i've been training for this my entire
life and i have no training at all yet
here i am ahead of you that's gotta be
embarrassing
listen i don't know if you're aware
rachel does not care for you at all
i'm aware
seriously bro
you got work to do
hey you thanks for coming tom really
glad you came really
uh like great to see you too
congratulations i mean you guys you guys
seem like really happy together you know
you're all right thomas bukowski
can we bury the hatchet
i'd love that yeah yeah all right bring
it in all right great oh and if you
scrub my wedding i will end you
sonic meet knuckles
you're no match for me
nailed it to face a new enemy you are
really bad at punching sonic will need a
fresh new look i make this look good
a ride or die crew uh did your butt just
turn into a helicopter
and laser focus you got a little
something on your feet
let's get out of here
oh great the winter soldier sonic the
hedgehog 2 coming soon
[Music]
quick stretch little snack and here we
go
sonic i love that you want to help
pretending to be batman blue justice
trademark pending
you're still just a kid
trust me there will come a moment when
your powers will be needed
but you don't choose that moment that
moment chooses you i just got goosebumps
wait a second did you steal that from
oprah
papa's got a brand new stash
since i've been gone i've discovered the
source of ultimate power
that sounds big
it's been on my vision board for years
hope i'm not too late
i'm sorry who are you
tales okay this is what we're gonna do
step one light taunting step two i have
no idea
[Music]
that wasn't too bad
today's forecast calls for a 100 chance
of adventure
[Music]
return to sender
face it you're never going to get my
power
do i look like i need your power
where
are my manners sonic meet knuckles
fear not citizens
i am the hero you need and deserve
okay
let's do this
people connected with sonic in such a
great way on the first film so i'm very
excited to go on a second sonic
adventure mind if i drive
it's great to step into a sequel
the audience just jazzed to see the next
one time to go for a ride everything's
been elevated
it's so fun to dive into the mythology
and to give the fans more of what they
want
papa's got a brand new stash
the bigger the ego the bigger the
mustache
it's not big enough as far as i'm
concerned
it is really exciting that we have our
main cast back in
[Music]
so help me thomas okay sorry sorry we
have some new characters we have tails
oh lord there's two of them now
we also have the ultimate match for
sonic
sonic
meet knuckles you're no match for me
i can't wait to show the fans the
knuckles character for a guy named
knuckles you are really bad at punching
it just gets bigger and better there's
more action
and more mischief hey you got a little
something on your
uh
return to sender
i was really excited to be a part of the
sonic world never thought in a million
years that i'd ever be a part of that
oh great the winner soldier
sonic the hedgehog you're no match for
me
i will destroy this planet
so nice when diabolical evil lives up to
the height
sonic this is your moment
we're unskilled
untrained
unworthy you forgot unstoppable
i think i just threw up in my mouth
i saw the hedgehog coming soon
these rings signify the
commitment so help me thomas sorry sorry
life or death situation i need you to
use the ring to save me like right now
snowmaker oh boy
ah hawaii i just hope we are not too
late oh lord there are two of them now
what's happening okay quick version
robotnik is back
i discovered the source of ultimate
power
we need to get it back for the world is
doomed
you got some kind of
space porcupine
i am an echidna warrior
hmm
hedgehog
it's time to say goodbye to humanity
this is your moment to be the big hero
bad time to say this but i don't
actually have a plan
hey you got a little something on your
uh
someone call an uber
it's cold in here
let's turn up the heat
oh great the winter soldier
fear not citizen you are terrible at
this your negative attitude is not
helping
we stick together
no matter what
you're unskilled
untrained
unworthy
you forgot one
unstoppable
[Music]
knuckles you are really bad at punching
[Music]
you